how do the results of this presidential
election reflect the will of the people
since more people voted for Hillary
Clinton than for Donald Trump and as the
votes continue to be counted we see that
in 2016 like in the year 2000 the
Democratic presidential candidate
received more votes in the popular vote
but ultimately lost the electoral vote
this is a screenshot from the New York
Times election tracker earlier today and
as you see Hillary Clinton receiving
about two hundred and thirty ish
thousand more votes than Donald Trump
today Donald Trump with more electoral
votes than Hillary Clinton but about a
quarter million fewer votes overall this
is the system that gave us George W Bush
and Donald Trump in spite of more votes
for the other candidates Al Gore and
Hillary Clinton respectively and because
of how the Electoral College works it's
actually possible mathematically for a
candidate to win the White House with
under thirty percent of the popular vote
Danielle Kurtz Leben from NPR recently
reported on this we must abolish this
ridiculous system now right-wing nuts
are going to email me Pat and they're
gonna say David you're saying that
because Hillary lost the election and
you just want to help Democrats well no
that's why I'm reminding you about it
today but I've been saying this for
years I've been talking about it for
nearly twenty years since I learned
about this harebrained system in middle
school the Electoral College a college
was established in 1787 and there's a
couple reasons why it was established
one of which was to put the power of the
election officially in the hands of
electors who I guess might be more
trustworthy conceivably than a national
popular vote and sort of create these 51
mini elections and another big part of
it was when you take away the popular
vote is the deciding a barometer for
elections you take power away from
population centers because if you have a
national popular vote candidates are
going to go where there are more people
they're going to go to the big cities
and they're going to ignore more rural
areas the problem is that by instituting
the electoral vote and set
this this primary system that we have
the two elements together have just
created an opposite problem where the
candidates rarely go to the population
centers and all of those who live in
cities are by and large ignored and
instead the candidates focus on
arbitrarily important states like Nevada
Ohio I'm sorry not Ohio New Hampshire
Iowa Nevada etc so I understand the
IdeaPad but it's created the exact same
problem just for a different group of
people and it's now happened four times
in American history that the winner of
the electoral vote actually lost the
popular vote meaning that less people
wanted them to become president yeah but
really it's not a partisan issue there's
usually not much to do about it in
Congress so I don't see it changing
anytime soon
I don't either and I'll talk to you
about what would happen for it to change
but I also want to mention one other
thing I mentioned that this electoral
college system was established in 1787
we didn't have media that allowed people
all over the country to see their
candidates if they didn't actually show
up in their town maybe you would
occasionally read about it in a
newspaper I am NOT less informed about
my choice in the 2016 election because I
didn't see the candidates speak in
person and that is something that we
have to think about much of the system
is more relevant the explanation for the
electoral college system makes more
sense when you can't just turn on your
TV no matter where you are or the radio
or the internet or open a newspaper and
see what it is that the candidates are
doing or saying now it's also not
democratic at the state level because
the Electoral College with the exception
of those two districts in Maine and the
two districts two or three districts in
Nebraska I forget exactly whether it's
two or three they're people who don't
vote the way that the majority in their
state votes essentially are not
represented in the results because it is
winner-take-all at the state level if we
switch to a popular vote system all of a
sudden every vote really does count and
this whole thing of well I'll vote third
party because my vote won't make a
difference in in because of the state
that I'm in that goes away Pat and every
vote does count and people's vote should
count equally across the country but
because of the Electoral College people
who live in small states and people who
live in swing states actually have a
more powerful vote than someone who
lives in
say California absolutely and this is
yet another way in which our country is
just really messed up and it would be
very difficult to change the electoral
college is part of our Constitution that
means we need a constitutional amendment
to change it that requires a two-thirds
vote in both the House and the Senate
and the ratification of 38 of the 50
states a few efforts have been made to
do this in 34 a vote to abolish the
Electoral College failed by two votes in
the Senate in 1979 the Senate debated a
direct election alternative that failed
51 to 48 shy of the two-thirds that it
needed and we've had this thing called
the national popular vote interstate
compact and the idea is get States to
commit to supporting electorally whoever
wins the popular vote what this would
allow states to do is if you are in
Indiana and Donald Trump wins Indiana
but Hillary Clinton wins the popular
vote
Indiana might say our electors will
actually support the winner of the
popular vote unfortunately only 11
states combining for a hundred and
sixty-five electoral votes have sort of
conditionally said that they would do
this and of course this isn't the system
that we have last thing on this this is
not some crazy unpopular idea back in
1948 Gallup surveyed people and asked
them do you want to get rid of the
electoral vote system 56% said yeah
let's get rid of it in 1967 that was up
to 58% and in 1968 that was up to 80%
and it didn't happen if you have 80
percent support for something in a
different era and that's not enough to
get change
Pat it's going to be going nowhere fast
isn't it there's this turn now about
moving against the elite and this would
be in a prime example of how we have to
move power back to the voters themselves
no doubt about it so we've got to get
rid of that we'll be talking about that
more next week and coming up although
there are there are better ways there
are other ways we can also affect future
election I've talked about how people of
all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car
you want it when you need it they offer
all sorts of cars suvs hybrids whatever
you need it includes insurance and it
includes gas you just pay for the time
that you actually use the car and you
can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between eleven hundred and
sixteen hundred pounds per year for our
audience
Zipcar is offering $25.00 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join zip car
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zip car
comm slash david